instead of us going to the market and
saying okay here's the value we create
here's what we charge for it we say
here's the value we create
here's what we would have charged but
here's the revenue instead we'll
generate
after we take our small cut for the
service so we're going into publishers
and saying we have a unique model that
will pay you
if you use our technology welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
in this next episode we're going to be
talking about media and startups but
we're also going to be talking about
this entrepreneur that
went from large companies now leading a
startup and and what that means for him
meet jeff kopitsky
ceo of jing an innovative technology
company helping publishers bring their
audience back
before joining jing jeff was president
and ceo
at oversee.net and served in leadership
positions with
x1 technologies digital insight of
intuit
siebel systems oracle loud cloud opsware
hewlett packard
and mckinsey company a frequent speaker
at digital media conferences
he has also been featured on cnn and
cnbc
jeff earned an mba from harvard business
school and his bachelor's of arts and
economics from columbia university
meet jeff jeff kopiecki how are you good
morning i'm doing well good morning to
you as well
i'm really excited to have you here jeff
uh talking about
jing now i think that your journey is
um a little unorthodox in the sense of
uh you starting this company now after
a columbia harvard mba and mckinsey
and then a lot of companies where you
were vice president and my memory is too
bad to even
begin listing them all but but after all
that you are now
working in the publishing space ai space
and search
and thinking through in 2021 how we get
the right content for the right people
with uh
and and you know things are changing
quickly and i'm excited to learn from
you
both about your journey and that so i'm
gonna ask what the easiest question of
them all
jeff who are you who is jeff well i'll
share a story because i i spent the
the early part of my career in silicon
valley i had the opportunity to work
with mark andreessen
and ben horowitz had a company called
opsware which uh
ended up being uh being sold to hb and
you know that's a very famous uh kind of
story there was a book written by ben
called the hard thing about hard things
and i i was with them during that period
and one of the things i loved the story
was they hired mbas but
not because they thought they knew
anything because it's like if you wanted
to build a hockey team
you wouldn't give them a video of how to
play hockey you'd say you know strap
on some pads and go learn the game on
the ice so i think that was for me
a good way to learn how to be an
entrepreneur how to think about starting
big businesses
and of course you learn a lot other
things along the way but my journey took
me from california
ultimately from northern california to
southern california which is where i'm
originally from
and then i looked east where i thought
there was a lot more opportunity and a
lot more interesting things going on and
ended up in the tel aviv area just about
10 years ago
now jing itself is not my startup
although i treat it that way
i actually was brought in when it was a
different focus
uh the chairman and founder of the
company is a brilliant man in aries
who started m systems which those
listeners might be familiar with is
disc on ki and he's the unsung partner
of dove
and arya had a vision for how email was
under
developed underutilized but the
application was around
banking and how to make banking more
interesting more secure using
email as a web basically conduit
and we took that technology and really
believed in it but we had to pivot a few
times to get it to where i think
ultimately
the best use case is which is in the
publishing industry
so walk me and that's exactly what i
want to talk about i want to understand
how do you come into a company and and
like i mentioned before we started
recording
the the amazing thing is here you've
done so much before you've had the
privilege really of choosing
your next challenge and the things
you're excited about and what i'm
hearing you is that there was this
interesting journey that you did within
jing
to find the right product market fit for
an amazing technology that was built and
i'm
especially curious to hear how does one
strategically
go about finding that you're starting
with an amazing technology
and finding the right use case how does
that work well the truth is you have to
have an idea of the market right so it's
product
market fit many times people focus too
much on the product
not too much on the market but you
really have to be thinking about what's
the market want and
i think in some ways we made like others
many mistakes
where we made certain assumptions and
they didn't come true but ultimately
there were learnings
along the way that kind of if you will
reiterated some of our core beliefs
about how we could improve the way that
content
was being connected with consumers and
that we had something to improve
in that process and really just to give
a quick intro what jing does today
we personalize content on behalf of
publishers
so that they can have a one-to-one
connection with their users
and the content they distribute in the
traditional publishing model
they create a lot of great content and
then wait for google and facebook and
basically the algorithms
to find it they bring those users in but
at that point there's no real control or
understanding
of that audience by the publisher and i
might even say
with no offense to your father that many
times google and facebook have taken out
the value
of that audience prior to giving it back
to the publisher
so our view is that publishers can be
empowered because they have great
content
to own their audience and bring them
back and the way they do that is by
creating
a way to understand what does that user
want when they're looking for news or
they're looking for information or
they're looking for hobby
you know tips and things that they're
interested in what is that user going to
respond to
and then how best can you as a publisher
position yourself
to give them that solution so what jing
has created is a very simple tool
that allows us to put javascript on a
web page categorize the content and then
help the publishers
by sending personalized messages that
could be pushed
that could be emailed in the future that
could be sms or for whatsapp etc
and the idea is to actually connect the
user with what they're really interested
in
and only that content so if you will
today you might be getting lots and lots
of email
that are not interesting we're going to
make it so that publishers send you only
something that you're interested in
and that's really the power of jane so
what i'm hearing here is that this
umbrella of personalization
right and this idea that you know we've
we've had publishers for i guess
thousands of years right ever since we
started writing and communicating
in in some language but now it's the
idea of this
the single message that you're creating
is not necessarily the right one
for for a lot of your audience and every
audience type cast has a different
need from that how do you go even about
trying to understand even logically
how to classify you know different
people based on their need
how do you even even try to understand
what is their need well the good news is
that because we're very much based on
email
there's a built-in identifier which is
your email address
and if you think about it as a consumer
you're going to open up your email
on your iphone on your samsung device on
a tablet at your work computer
so you've got multiple places that
you're accessing content
that historically if they only use
cookies which are going away as you know
then you're not going to be seen as a
single individual but really a user
wants to be seen as logged in
when you access facebook or twitter or
google you're always logged in
a publisher doesn't get that benefit
because the users are coming if you will
on discrete
channels what we do is we use the email
address it's hash
so it's not identified to a specific
individual but it's unique
and then we can find what that user is
interested in by looking at their
behavior
across the channels so in the morning
you might be looking up sports scores
in the middle days might be your stocks
and you know later in the day you're
kind of looking up ski slopes and
information about uh
you know where the best powder is going
to be this weekend and putting all that
all together under the same
if you will identifier allows us to
build a profile
of that user and provide that to the
publisher so they can target the right
content
not just of the right channel but also
at the right time to make it most more
engaging for the consumer
now this brings me to my favorite
conversation which is around privacy
and you know i i know where i'm on the
spectrum and i'm on an extreme end of
the spectrum probably very much on your
end
but but tell me a little bit about the
conversation of privacy that arises here
that
you know a lot of like the older
generation or the people that aren't
born with a smartphone in their hand
immediately they're the the hairs on the
back of their neck rise up as soon as
you start saying something like
we see what the user is doing and based
on that we we do something
well we absolutely believe that the user
has to control
the relationship of their data and
that's why again when the industry had
been historically based on cookies
there's no permission based typically in
the united states obviously europe has
something else
but with using email address that's a if
you will identifier
that the user has complete control over
they determine
when somebody uh uses that information
they can always unsubscribe they always
say don't use my data
and that gives control to the user but
you'd be interested to know that we've
done some surveys
where people tell us they're very
comfortable sharing information
if it means they get more personalized
content we talk about keeping the press
free and what we mean by that is not
meaning just independent
we mean it as not to be charged for most
consumers don't want to pay for content
and they recognize they've got to see
some advertising in order to read those
articles that they love
see the videos that they love without
having to pay for that content
and we think that the future world is
not going to be based on paid
subscription
but based on advertising supported
curated content
and that's where we can help support
publishers and maintain a free
or independent press and i have to say
you know anecdote about myself i
remember the times when everybody was
talking about how facebook is listening
to our microphones and
to determine the news feed and i
remember well well everybody were you
know appalled by this i was actually
excited by the notion
that i'm like i want to give all the
information possible so that i can get
the best experience on
social media but you know maybe that is
a little bit of as long as you can
control it that's our view and i think
consumers
who know that and can stay in control uh
will feel better about that trade-off
now walk me through the higher picture
here so
great you're connecting publishers with
the right consumers with the right
content
win-win situation what does this do
to the world of content what does this
do to the world of advertising
as we know it and i'm excited to ask you
this in 2021 and
and you know i'll watch this back in a
few years and and you know it's it's a
it's because it's an ever
it's a changing consumer idea right so
first of all for consumers this is
extremely important
right because if we don't have multiple
sources
of invested content meaning where people
are writing it and there's curation
we're going to be left with you know no
offense but whatever we find on social
media
and that's the worst place to get our
news and information
it doesn't provide i think uh you know
diversity of thought and opinion
it doesn't necessarily lead us so we
won't go all the way there but i think
you know where i'm getting at is
we as a society need an independent
press and that's very important we need
a business model
for publishers that can scale that's
sufficient we've had that for many years
it's advertising let's kind of look at
where the world is going
we're moving from kind of untargeted
brand based typically analog advertising
right so tv radio outdoor and moving
more towards
targeted performance digital advertising
which is obviously where digital media
comes in
but publishers have not gotten their
fair share of that pie
sure facebook google amazon they
continue to get a bigger share
of that pie as it grows our view is that
the world will eventually come back to
where
those who create great content aggregate
audience
will get a better share of that
advertising pie
and companies like ours i believe will
help those publishers because they don't
have the resources to build the ai
to understand what they need in terms of
user preference to even
the playing field a bit so that they can
have a logged in user experience
similar to what google facebook and
amazon can create
right and i think that you know a
different trend that is separate but
similar that i'm personally excited
about is this whole idea of the creator
economy
and you know i think if previously um
we'd consider publishers to be you know
these big brands that are creating
content
well today you know i you know i'm i'm
it's crazy to me that i am a publisher i
guess
you are through one and it's and it's
weird because
at the end of the day it's becoming more
and more apparent that everybody every
person can be a publisher
uh whether they like it or not uh you
know by by gratitude of us being
online talk to me a little bit about the
business of this so
the business of of publishers and
consumers
this whole space that you're in how does
the economics actually work
i'm really curious about that yeah so
we're a typical software company and
that there's a price for our service
what makes us though very unique is that
when we tell our publishers
you can pay us to use the platform or we
have a better idea
because you're in the business of
aggregating audience and then serving
them advertising
how about we serve the advertising on
your behalf
every send that you do we'll put in
advertising that you call you know
you can uh decide we solicit it
then we can do it as a revenue share so
instead of us going to the market and
saying okay
here's the value we create here's what
we charge for it we say
we would have charged but here's the
revenue instead
we'll generate after we take our small
cut for the service
so we're going into publishers and
saying we have a unique model that will
pay you
if you use our technology and so that's
really allowed us to scale it much
faster
than we would have in a traditional sas
model
so you enter a room and you tell a
publisher that you're going to pay him
if he uses your software
or she of course and what what is the
reaction
i mean it's because it's a little bit
it's a it's a little bit mind-boggling
right well we joke there was no reason
we had called the company jing but
every time i say that phrase i hear
kajing that's more money in my pocket so
let's leave it at that i i love it now
now jeff you've done a lot
and you've gone through a lot of
different milestones uh executive at a
variety of companies
worked with with ben and mark that's
that's amazing
and harvard i worked with four
billionaires i think over my career
so tom siebel
the pioneers pioneers of of the tech
ecosystem and the internet really and
we're much more i think than you know
it's really you know when i hear those
names i get excited just by virtue of
what they've done to this to society
and you chose jing as your next
you know baby and your next passion
project
walk me a little bit through the thought
process of a of a tech veteran executive
that has the pleasure of choosing
whatever opportunity
he wants why why jane yeah well my prior
role was i was ceo of a a larger media
company based in los
angeles called overseas.net we were one
of the largest uh kind of a fuel
uh players in the internet real estate
so domain names and things like that and
after i decided to transition there you
know to be honest i was going over to
israel and i thought you know what
there's two types of companies i can go
to a bigger company and apply my trade
where i could really start much earlier
and learn a lot more for myself
and i think looking back it was the more
risky kind of move and probably took a
bit longer than i expected but
it's been much more fulfilling to be
there in the early stages to make those
mistakes to have to recover from them
and then build something from that uh
and so i've been very pleased with the
opportunity that i i had and to be
honest it's really because of arya and
the board and
others that have uh i think had faith in
what we're doing that we've been able to
kind of stay at it as long as we have
how how does the leadership that you
have to exert
differ from being the ceo of a large
company before
now you're running a smaller company
startup
how does that change i think you get
involved in much more of the
the the nitty gritty if you will you end
up getting more involved in marketing
and product
and obviously early hr decisions
recruiting things like that but i think
i was
less i think as engaged again if you if
you're a person that likes building and
likes getting involved it's great
but that's generally one of the changes
i like to think of it is i was more
challenged when the company was smaller
as we're now getting bigger i'm getting
more comfortable again
to things i recognize so i feel like i'm
playing more to my strengths
as we get bigger so i used to joke on
management 2.0
i come with a 3.0 mindset to a 1.0
situation and
eventually balances out i love that
now a little bit about challenges
i i'd really love to hear you know
sometimes throughout throughout this
really glamorous career that said wow
like i'm
stumped i'm surprised i'm this is
something that's that's not trivial
and you know those are those are i think
the learning moments that i get excited
by
did you have any of those all the time i
definitely encourage your listeners to
always ask call a friend you know as
ceos that's the
last thing we like to think about is
that we don't know the answer and we
have to actually show some uh
i think uh vulnerability and say i don't
know the answer let me go ask so
i'm part of a ceo group where we ask
each other all the time for help and
you know can you help me out and this is
what i'm struggling with and i tell
everybody that in the other day it's
really the collaboration of great minds
they'll get the right answer so
you have to ask those questions right
and i think that one of the things i was
actually
talking to um a big investor here in
israel in venture capital and he was
saying how
you know the one of the struggles that
he sees is that as a vc you have to also
foster a a space a safe and trusting
space where
the ceo and the founder can actually
exert that ins that vulnerability
which today according to linkedin and
crunchbase and techcrunch
you're really not supposed to do because
it's supposed to be all
bravo right oh right
i i'd say you can ask it doesn't have to
be over linkedin or facebook but
you know the human context still works
you know picking up a phone talking in
person
that's still unparalleled exactly
jeff i really want to thank you for
taking time out of the your busy
schedule to be here i really appreciate
it
i have a few questions not about jing
not about your career but
about you if you're ready for them go
ahead
we're going back to middle school and
high school
what was your favorite subject i think
history
i think the more i kind of learned and
look back about the something i got most
excited about i always believe
everything you need to do in the future
something happened in the past that you
could learn from so the more you
understand that path the more at least
you'll make only new mistakes
and somebody throughout your career or
now that serves as some sort of
inspiration some sort of
role model yeah this is going to found a
little bit corny and non-high techy but
for those who are familiar with the
personal life of maimonides
i always found that to be very inspiring
he obviously was considered an art
tradition to be a great
uh thinker leader mystic you know
prolific writer
but he actually had a great day job he
was the physician to the sultan and
you know he actually was pretty busy uh
in his field
and that idea that he was able to blend
this kind of personal and uh
professional together to achieve what he
did i think is very inspirational
amazing and what are three words that
you
would choose for yourself might not be
what other people know about me but
i'll start with i hope uh integrity you
know you get what you hear and there
shouldn't be any difference
humor when you don't get what you know
i'm probably kidding about it then
most important probably is perseverance
and the end of the day
those who kind of succeed are the ones
who just stick with it
jeff thank you very very much this was a
wonderful
and uh and and i learned a lot both you
know on a personal level but also on a
professional level and it just makes me
want to go
dig deeper into into what you're doing
and where this where this economy
is moving and where this consumer
behavior is shifting best of luck with
jing
and stay safe and stay home thank you
very much michael i appreciate your time
thank you take care
[Music]
you